[Music]  I'd like each of you to get up and tell  us a five minutes story about your  summer at some point you make a choice  about who you are what you want  [Music]  ham Roux I'm an addict about the start  of a new chapter some new girl in town  that I think you've all been friends  with I'm real and Jules  suddenly the whole world goes dark  nothing else matters but the person  standing in front of you  I'm Denby so your generation you guys  don't care as much about the rules  they're just reaching for something to  make it all seem meaningful  [Music]  [Applause]  every time I feel good I think it'll  last forever but it doesn't nothing  lasts forever  my idea should I be concerned  you think cuz I went to rehab uh safely  I mean ain't at the point  I could be a different person  I would  [Music]  maybe just take your time  got I can't  but everyone I love to at least try and  change  [Music]